katia bonjour alors que dire de ce texte
que les députés s'apprêtent à voter cet
après-midi ou et bien c'est un texte
très dense inquiet a provoqué beaucoup
de débat la gauche par exemple a estimé
que le texte pouvait être stigmatisant
quant à la droite elle a accusé de ne
pas assez ciblées l'islamisme en
revanche d'entravé d'autres cultes alors
au cours de ces 80 heures de plénière le
texte a été finalement assez peu amendé
vous le disiez 1 144 amendement retenu
sur 2700 et encore ils venaient
principalement de la majorité alors
quels sont les objectifs de ce texte de
51 article et bien s'attaquer à
l'islamisme comment par exemple en
renforçant la neutralité du service
public en luttant contre la haine en
ligne et surtout en assurant des
contrôles à leurs contrôles tous azimuts
notamment sur les lieux de culte en
contrôlant davantage leurs financements
notamment étrangers et puis en assurant
des fermetures facilité en cas de
dérapage contrôle des associations
notamment les associations sportives il
ya un volet contre la polygamie contre
les mariages forcés et puis un nouveau
délit a été créé en réaction à
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit délit de
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui par la
diffusion malveillante de d'informations
privées alors un autre sujet a divisé
les parlementaires l'article 21 il
oblige les parents à scolariser leurs
enfants alors sauf dans certains cas
comme la santé ou l'itinérance des
parents et il a fait particulièrement
gloser et puis autre autre aspect ans de
ce texte s'il a provoqué quelques
mobilisation portant sur divers aspects
du texte mais finalement elles n'ont pas
été aussi forte que les oppositions créé
par le projet de loi sur la sécurité
globale
merci beaucoup catia pour toutes ces
précisions katia technique en direct de
l'assemblée nationale